when did you see steve's like alcoholism
kick in did you know that he had a
problem with drugs and alcohol
the dad's answer to every question is
well i wasn't in the country i heard
about it no no
no no i think it became apparent to me
in uh in toronto
um when i was in seventh grade
yeah yeah you you found a uh i stole a
bottle of wine
yeah and you got wasted and you puked
all over the place
and uh your mom was there to sort of for
the first
first responder and uh when i got home
that's when i was really worried because
concurrent with that you had a little
pup tent or something
and uh i ran away from home you you you
ran
about the equivalent of half a dozen
city blocks from home
and pitched your tent in a little ravine
behind the house
but uh i i made it further than that i
made it uh
like i had to take one bus and get off
no i didn't get on a second bus because
that's what i did every morning to get
to school
and i walked through this i thought you
were closer
anyway that's how i do this i told my
sister
my plans i said i'm gonna run away i'm
gonna live in this ravine
and uh and i set up my tent i was in the
tent you know i haven't run away now
mind you i ran away with no
money with no food why'd you run away
because you got in trouble for the
bottle of wine god knows no i didn't run
away from
trouble for the worst i didn't i had
nothing but that that that that's when i
started to worry
right and then london came after that
and somehow when you were with the
skateboarding
things improved i kind of breathed a
sigh of relief and
thought we were out of the woods and
clearly we weren't
right so when did you realize you were
in the woods still
maybe when my report card came back from
the university of miami and i
achieved over the course of the whole
semester a cumulative gpa of
0.79 yeah what was it
well i i i i i said uh i looked for the
silver lining
and there was there was a good side of
that
you flamed out so fast i didn't piss
away a lot of money
useless education right we're gonna blow
it blow it quick
yeah yeah quick let's make that only uh
one year of tuition you know
it's obviously sad and
lest the wrong impression is being
created
we can talk about this now and laugh
sure because
it's behind us and you've turned out
fantastically well
but when i look back i don't think i
realized how scary it was
yeah and uh it's certainly uh
i don't want to convey the wrong
impression by laughing about it now
right
i mean we had a real uh
pretty heavy talk i remember i think it
was the night that
the reelection of george w bush was
unfolding in 2004
and we were talking about how uh
we were talking about how um
when i dropped out of the university of
miami i i had
zero communication with you for a full
six months you did not know where i was
in the world that's correct you heard
nothing about me
you didn't know if i was alive if i was
safe and in fact i was having the
government test dangerous drugs on me
for money and you didn't know that or
anything
and uh and and i said to uh i said to
you about that whole period of time
where i was off the radar
that uh i said uh something like
you know i said dad you weren't gonna
pay me
to be a piece of [__] that wasn't doing
anything that you approved of
and you said you didn't give me the
opportunity
you know which is pretty heavy you know
almost suggesting that he would have
helped me out if i reached out
but i had too much pride to reach out
and you know what
you're right i would have and with
hindsight
i value the pride and helping you out
would have been enabling that trend
100 it's like i i have a philosophy
about
parents who help out their kids
financially too much it's very much like
if you break a bone you got to have a
cast on that bone while it heals
you know like like like a kid is it
needs help like in order to become an
adult
but much like if the bone is healed and
you leave that cast on
then you don't need to cast because the
bone is healed and
by having the cast on your muscles
atrophy they become weak they become
useless and ultimately you're in much
worse position
and uh so many so many parents
view helping out their kids financially
as
like some kind of a positive thing when
in fact it's very much just leaving that
cast on and and it's
you got a lame duck kid that never
learns how to
how to fend for themselves you know
i guess it was after that time you were
uh back in london
uh i think it was no it was uh
uh connecticut no it was
uh just getting the years straight
florida
and you were staying with your mom and
uh i'll never forget
uh she kicked me out on christmas she
kicked you out on christmas morning
and yeah i've always respected her for
that
and to this day i know i wouldn't have
the strength of character to do that
yeah it's tough what'd you do on
christmas morning i did something like
he came up
we we had an apartment in tequesta and
you came up
and at that at that time everything was
closed down
on christmas day i don't know what plan
had existed before you showed up
but i remember we went to an ihop to
celebrate the christmas meal
and i think you i i forget what you
stayed with us
for a while and i forget what happened
after that
um i mean mom kicked me out
like a number of times how old are you
at this point at that time i would have
been
20 into 21. and uh it was just like look
you know
you're not willing to get a job you're
[__] making a mess
you know you're acting like an [__]
you say you're gonna do something you
don't do it like i've had enough get the
[__] out
you know like i and uh yeah i totally
deserved it
and i always um like ended up on
someone's sofa or something
mm-hmm you know yeah how old would your
mom been at that point in time
uh if i was 20 21 this was in your age
now
um i'm not that quick
what year what year was that that would
have been 1994.95
like 40 or 50. uh she uh
was she born or how old would she when
steve was born
i mean i don't know let's not waste our
our valuables but probably close to your
age right now
i mean i know that she was what was she
50 when uh
she turned 40 when we were in toronto
which which
um so she would have been late 40s right
so basically your age
just think like could you imagine being
in that position now telling a 21 year
old kid to get the [__] out of your head
like your own kid you know
i mean hey if you baby them you bury
them can i just tell you how
[__] up my new tour is it's completely
multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [__] man because
it's gnarly and it's all the stuff i
wasn't allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [__] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats